good luck a happiness and then here it
says the start to a new life 10 words
quickly written on to the only bit of
paper an American soldier could find
this German banknote
Lily Ebert was 16 in April 1945 when she
and her sisters were liberated from a
death march they'd survived Auschwitz
but lost everything we are not that
piece of paper
we have nothing people you cannot know
that and you cannot explain especially
to babes nothing you had the wrong body
you and our new body and that was it
in just over four and a half years Nazi
Germany systematically murdered nearly a
million Jews in Auschwitz somehow she
and her two sisters survived lost my
family my brothers uncles hundred I am
sure now ninety she found the notes
while going through her possessions with
her great-grandson who had the idea of
trying to trace the soldier who wrote it
it's with my great-grandma that I'd be
able to find the soldier in 24 hours and
lo and behold with the help of Twitter
we managed to find him in 24 hours which
is just amazing I loved his post ended
up being retweeted by the Auschwitz
Museum shared over a million times and
social media users were able to piece
together that it was a private Hyman
Shulman who wrote the note sadly he died
seven years ago but this weekend lily
and her family will be video chatting
with his children and as a very
important message she wants them to know
these men was really the first nice
human touch and that makes made
something so that you remember that is
important well-worn
but it is the compassion the kindness
that Lily will never forget
Katie Spencer Sky News